es su cuarto invierno en este campamento
en el noreste de siria
aquí 200 niños franceses han sido
reunidos con varias decenas de otros
menores europeos
las condiciones de vida son duras
todos estos niños tienen o tuvieron
padres yihadistas hace años
que quisieras
que recuerdas de parís
en los últimos dos años francia ha
repatriado a 35 niños se les da
prioridad a los huérfanos y a los
menores que tienen una salud frágil es
un proceso lento y cauteloso les
preocupa la educación de los niños y si
ellos podrían suponer una amenaza para
el país las autoridades kurdas que
controlan el campamento nos permiten
grabar las clases de costura y
peluquería una forma de mantener a las
niñas ocupadas y devolverles a enseñar a
vivir lejos de las restricciones del
autodenominado grupo estado islámico
esta joven francesa de 14 años cuenta
los días hasta que se le permita salir
honestamente no eres libre no puedes
salir del campamento es como estar en
prisión es agotador
cuando has pasado casi cuatro años aquí
y ves que otros niños se van te
preguntás cuando te tocará a ti
personalmente no siento que yo sea un
peligro para los demás no he hecho nada
no hemos hecho nada no sé por qué la
gente nos tendría miedo
pero si irme significa estar separada de
mi familia mientras sin mamá está en la
cárcel entonces no quiero eso
por temor a que sigan estando
radicalizadas francia les prohibió
regresar a las madres
la última vez que accedemos a un campo
hace más de dos años la mayoría de las
madres no querían separarse de sus hijos
esta vez nos encontramos con emily
koning una antigua reclutadora de
yihadistas
este vídeo la muestra con un arma
propaganda para el grupo yihadista
finalmente dejó que sus tres hijos
regresarán a francia volvieron a casa en
enero
no es algo que queramos elegir si solo
pensar en mí me habría quedado con ellos
pero si pienso en ellos hago que vuelvan
la más pequeña tiene problemas
respiratorios no puedo mantenerla aquí
en estas condiciones
mi hijo empezará la primaria en
septiembre
pero a francia le preocupa que sus hijos
estén adoctrinados adoctrinados como mi
hijo está loco por dragon ball z
canta todas las canciones de los dibujos
animados si estuviera radicalizado no
cantaría las canciones de los dibujos
animados
esta otra madre les permitió volver a
sus hijos hace un año y medio
sé que van a la escuela que a mi hija le
va muy bien se llevan bien con sus
familias de acogida les cae muy bien la
persona que los cuida se ocupa de ellos
no veo por qué deberían estar en la
cárcel conmigo fui yo quien decidió
venir aquí de nada sirve que ellos
paguen también las organizaciones
humanitarias y varios diputados piden
que los niños sean repatriados con sus
madres si es necesario dicen estar
preocupados por el bienestar de los
niños y no quieren que desarrollen
deseos de venganza